-It is great to see you.
-It is so good to see you.
-You know what I miss
about you?
-What?
-A lot. But your laugh.
I love your laugh.
-It's a lot.
-You have a great laugh.
-It's a cackle.
It is a cackle.
-When it eventually,
you don't fake it.
So, yeah.
-It is honestly it is karma.
This is my mom's laugh.
And as a child,
I tormented her over her laugh.
Whenever I was doing a school
play or something, I was like,
"I always know where you are
in the theater, mom.
[ Light laughter ]
Like,
just tone it down a little bit."
-Then look at you,
now you have it.
Your kids know
when you are laughing?
-Yeah, and they are just
as annoyed as I am.
-You are an amazing actor.
And I told you this right
before the show,
but I want to tell you again.
Some of the best directing --
you directed "The Mandalorian"
and "The Book of Boba Fett."
You are amazing. Fantastic.
I mean, congrats.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's incredible
working for Jon Favreau.
-Jon Favreau is great too,
he's a genius.
-But I worked with you.
You directed me in a movie.
-Last time we saw each other,
I was interviewing
you for hours.
-Yeah. It was fun though.
-Yeah, you were amazing.
-And I watched this episode.
It was crazy.
As I was watching I am like,
"who directed this
because this is really --"
and you did it.
You hit a home run, buddy.
What is it like to direct
a "Star Wars" project?
-It's incredible.
But for me personally, it is all
the more meaningful
because I was very lucky.
I got to grow up basically
on my dad's movie sets
and George Lucas.
Since my dad was 17,
George Lucas has been
my dad's mentor.
Because my Dad did --
-"American Graffiti."
Yeah, exactly.
-I mean, come on.
-Exactly, and George has kids
the same age
as all of the kids in my family.
So we were all kind of raised
together.
And then I actually went to
summer camp
with Natalie Portman
before she did the prequels.
And because I knew George,
and all that kind of stuff,
I got to go visit
a bunch on the prequels.
And so it's a very
personal thing
that I feel very protective of.
Of "Star Wars."
-The "Star Wars."
-Of the "Star Wars."
-So when you you get involved
with that, and asked to do that,
did you ask George?
Did you ask --how did you get
in that world,
and like, "Hey,
I would like a shot at this."
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So what happened is,
I just finished filming
"Jurassic World:
Fallen Kingdom,"
which is the movie before the
one that came out today.
-Whoo!
-Why thank you.
My dad started to direct
on "Solo."
And I was like, "Can I stay in
the UK and shadow you, please?"
And he said, "No."
And I just kind of begged
and pleaded and said,
"I'll just be very quiet on set,
and nobody will realize
I am there."
-Just try not to laugh.
-Yeah, just don't laugh.
I don't think
I was successful at that.
And so I got to go and shadow
and learn from him.
It was incredible as well.
Because I hadn't seen him
direct onset since I was a kid.
And now being an actor,
and having had a couple
of decades doing this.
I am like, "oh, wow.
You are really good."
-He knows how to do it, yeah.
-And so, I met folks there.
They brought me aboard
to write something.
And that's how I started to get
to know the folks at Lucasfilm.
-Cause Lucasfilm,
they also develop new stuff
people even haven't seen.
They're just working on ideas
on the next thing.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But you directed Baby Yoda.
-Oh, yeah.
I get to do that, yeah.
-But Baby Yoda is real though?
[ Light laughter ]
-Baby Yoda is totally real,
totally real -- completely.
One of the reasons why Jon
Favreau was so supportive of me
working with the legacy team
that developed
Baby Yoda,
was because I met them
and worked with them
both "Terminator"
and the original
"Jurassic World."
And so I knew
that team of puppeteers.
-It's amazing what they do.
That little thing is probably
the cutest thing
I think I have ever seen,
besides my own children.
[ Laughter ]
You know, it's so cute.
I go, "please do another scene
with Baby Yoda."
I love him so much.
-I mean, I concur.
Yeah.
Baby Yoda is the best.
-You just fall
in love with him.
-Yeah, yeah.
And that's why Baby Yoda
has a lot of protection onset.
Because we all are just looking
at Baby Yoda all the time.
Being like, "I just want to
take that Baby Yoda."
It's very visceral.
You know?
-Just squeeze it. And I go, "I
love you. You're so cute."
-Did you know,
this might be wrong,
but this is what I've heard,
that the violence part of your
brain is right next to the cute
part of your brain.
So when you think
something's really cute,
it bumps up against the violence
part of your brain, you're like,
"I just want to
smush it to death."
[ Laughter ]
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-That's what I heard.
-I did not know that.
-That's why if you see
something really cute,
it becomes, like at a certain
point, very gruesome.
"I just want to smother it.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just gonna --"
-Yeah. Yeah.
It's so cute, yeah.
-"Push it down."
You know.
-You were saying that you are
a big "Star Wars" fan.
And I go, "Yes,
I agree with you."
You had something painted
on the side of your house.
-Yeah.
-I just go, "This is cool."
And you were nice enough
to take a photo.
-It is a mural on the side
of my house of the twin suns
of Tatooine.
-That's "Star Wars" next level.
I mean, how did the family --
-I begged. I begged.
My husband was supportive.
My kids are like,
"What are you doing, mom?
On the side of our house?"
-I love that.
-Can't get enough of it.
I love it.
-Can we talk about
"Jurassic World."
-Yes, please.
Our movie.
Our franchise.
-That's right.
That's correct.
-Gyrosphere guy, everyone.
-Thank you.
Please hold your applause.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, you are.
That's interesting, oh you are.
I was in, if you don't remember,
please hold your applause --
-How could you forget?
-Would you forget?
Apparently our audience did,
but I was in the first
"Jurassic World."
I was there.
I was the gyrosphere --
-Gyrosphere.
-Gyrosphere scientist guy.
We had Chris Pratt on,
and I said,
"I was thinking
of reprising my character."
And he goes, "Your 'character'?"
[ Laughter ]
He goes,
"You played you in that movie."
But, yeah, either way.
-No small actors,
only small parts.
-But we created a dynasty,
you and I.
-Yes. Just us.
-In "Jurassic World."
Basically just us,
and here we are -- reunited.
Like, we're labeling this show
"The Reunion" --
-Oh!
-Because we are back together.
-Because it's finally.
-Finally --
Jeff Goldblum, Laura Dern.
That's all good and funny.
-Jimmy Fallon.
-When's Jimmy and Bryce
going to get back together?
Because we weren't even
in the scene together.
-I know, we should eventise it.
You know?
-We should. We are.
People are glued.
-They are clamoring for this.
-"They're like, "Jimmy, are you
going to do another voiceover
for a LEGO video game?"
"Yeah."
"An unlockable character?"
"Sure."
Why would you want
to unlock my character?
But you can unlock it.
I give facts about dinosaurs.
-Very cool.
-But this one is kind of --
this is the end.
-Yeah, it's the conclusion.
It is the epic conclusion
of the "Jurassic" franchise
that started
all of those years ago.
[ Audience aws ]
-But it pays off.
Everyone's story pays off.
-Yeah, I mean, it's really
incredible to get to be
a part of this franchise
that has spanned
such an immense amount of time.
And to have Laura Dern,
and Jeff Goldblum,
and Sam Neil, and B.D. Wong,back
in this movie with all of us.
And it's not --
it's an ensemble.
This is all of our movie.
They don't have cameos.
This is their movie as much
as it is any of ours.
It was a blast.
-And you see you guys all
on the screen then you hear --
and I am like, [Vocalizes]
"Don't cry, Jimmy. Don't cry.
You were in this movie
at one point. Remember?"
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I go, "Look what you guys
have become.
I remember when you
were this tall."
-Stay jaded. Stay jaded.
-Stay jaded.
When I did the first "Jurassic
World" everyone was this tall.
And I was like, "Oh, so cute,
Chris Pratt.
You're going to
grow up one day."
And then look at you guys now,
I'm watching on the IMAX.
-You know what's crazy?
When Chris Pratt
did the first Jurassic,
"Guardians of the Galaxy"
had not come out yet.
So he was the guy
from "Parks and Rec."
When he was doing the first
"Jurassic World."
And he was like, "Oh, I hope
this thing I did,
"Guardians" works out."
And I was like, 'Dude,
you are Starlord.
It is going to be incredible."
-It worked out pretty well.
-Yeah, I'll say.
So, it's just awesome.
It's been incredible
getting to go on this journey.
Because this has been --
these eight years
have really represented
so much in all of our lives.
-Eight years. It's awesome.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Bryce Dallas Howard
in "Jurassic World: Dominion."
Take a look at this.
[ Dinosaur roars ]
-[ Grunts, groans ]
Aah!
[ Dinosaur roaring ]
[ Panting ]
♪♪
[ Bell tolling ]
[ Breathing heavily ]
[ Grunts ]
[ Dinosaur roars ]
-That's what I am talking
about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is how you do it, buddy.
Bryce Dallas Howard, everybody.
"Jurassic World: Dominion"
is in theaters and IMAX today.